hello everyone and welcome to the final
round of this year's singfield cup where
the leader Fabiano corana is facing off
against rard rort who is not having the
greatest tournament still without a
single win it's not easy to win against
this opposition even fabbi having only
only two wins against alz and wle so but
uh uh well who whoever you beat is an
incredibly strong player and it goes a
long way and in the previous video we've
mentioned that Faby reached this new
plateau uh he once again hit 2800 on the
live ratings list and now uh it's sort
of a a different uh different Universe
to exist in and now whoever you're
playing it's sort of the case for magnet
for the past um decade uh whoever you
play if you if you draw uh you lose
rating and then okay it was also true
before this game because he was very
close to 2800 but um uh now that he
actually broke 2800 now that um that's
also maybe a a psychological barrier
that you have going into every game I'm
not I'm not saying or I don't even think
that Fabby would have such a barrier I
think he just plays every game to win as
um as much as he can uh but still it's
nice that now we have two 2800 players
uh in the world it's not official yet
still uh Fabby has ended the month with
2,800 on the live ratings but as there
are no more tournaments after this one
uh I'm guessing it um will be possible
uh so let's uh let's check it out Fabby
has the white pieces and he opens with
Pawn to D4 and uh Rapport goes for
Knight to F6 we have C4 C6 preparing for
the slob defense Knight to F3 and the D5
the slob defense is on the board Knight
to C3 and E6 transposing into the semi
slav defense with have E3 and now there
are some moves that are usually played
here Knight bat to D7 is the top move
here there are some others like Bishop
to D Bishop D7 can play Bishop to D6 A6
or maybe some of the Lesser played moves
but raer plays G6 and it's a very very
very rare move and very rarely played at
the top level so Bishop to D3 uh we have
Bishop to G7 and now both players Castle
we have Pawn to E4 and Fabby plays D
captures sorry rapper plays D captures
on e4 and now Fabby does not play Knight
captures and there are some 35 games
maybe in the database where Knight
captures play he actually plays Bishop
captures on e4 showing that 2800 can
play literally anything and it looks
weird why would you allow Knight
captures on e4 but Knight captures on e4
is not a very impressive um move to play
because if you play this after Knight
captures on e4 try and find a move for
black here it's really it's really not
easy uh whatever you decide to do will
be uh will be met with uh some sort of a
bishop to G5 move that gains control
over F6 and it's just very very
unpleasant okay E5 is the top move
recommended by the engine it's a pawn
sacrifice but you know if you have to
conceit you a pawn sacrifice and move 10
then already you've messed something up
if it's um if it's a you know a
voluntary SA rice then okay but if you
have to ConEd it it then it's not the
point is let something like B6 Bishop to
G5 attacks the queen you already have to
play F6 and now after the bishop moves
uh let's say C5 uh you run into some
nasty tactics like Bishop here and
you're going to lose the C5 Pawn so
that's why after Bishop captures on e4
rapper plays Knight Knight bd7 this was
already played but Pawn to B5 and it is
now as of move nine then we have a
completely new game and there's a very
tricky idea behind Pawn to B5 if should
capture then rort will capture on e4 and
after Knight captures he will play C
captures on B5 and sort of
um it's it's a bit different because now
if let's say Bishop G5 you can also play
Queen D5 with Tempo you attack the
Knight and then if Rook goes here the
Knight goes here and so on and you will
also gain control over this diagonal
which will long-term be very good for
black so instead after this B5 move fby
just goes back Bishop to D3 we have B
captures and C4 Bishop captures and now
Bishop to A6 attacking the bishop on C4
and we have a trade captures captures
and queen to A4 and if you ever played
against the Queen's Pawn opening and you
play like the the nimzo Indian or some
other openings you might run into Queen
to a for quite a lot I know I do and
that it always annoys me because it's
very hard to to actually deal with it so
now you have to deal with the Knight and
the C6 Pawn here rapper plays Queen to
B6 defends both and now Bishop to F4 you
don't care about the B2 Pawn of course
as the Knight here is hanging uh but it
is a line that we should explore because
it's uh it it it can get very crazy to
give you an example if Queen captures on
B2 uh Bishop to D6 is the in between
move a very nice fision T and after Rook
to d8 you will attack The Rook once
again and after The Rook attacks the
bishop now you play Bishop captures and
F6 that's the problem and the bishop
captures and now still you don't trade
first you go for Knight the E4 and now
look at this the bishop hangs with check
and also the Knight on A6 is hanging and
best you can do is just play Bishop
captur on D4 sort of to try and give up
a knight here but you will not even do
that you will play Rook eight to B1 and
you will go after the black queen uh the
black queen not really having all that
many squares here let's say queen to E2
Rook F to E1 You'll Play Queen to D3 now
Rook B to D1 and now you have to play
something like Queen to B5 and uh ju
just give up a piece to survive the
attack Rook captures on D4 and white
will be up a piece so Queen cap on B2 is
not merely a trade of of pieces you will
also just lose the game terribly so Rook
F to d8 by raer instead putting pressure
on that D4 pawn and Fabby defends it
Bishop to E5 we have Knight to B4 and
now the Knight wants to come to D3 to
put pressure on the bishop so Fabby
defends it Rook F to D1 we have Knight B
to D5 centralizing the Knight and now
Queen back to C2 so okay rapper defended
well uh Bishop to f8 and now uh Fabby
could play some developing moves like
Rook eight to C1 he could also maybe
play H4 with the potential of a future
H5
but he goes for none of that he plays
Knight to G5 and what's the idea behind
this move well it's just a very annoying
Knight to look at if you're playing
Black here and you can't just kick it
away if you kick it away the Knight
captures an E6 check and you weaken the
G6 square and you're just going to lose
the game here for example Bishop G7 you
eliminate the defender of the F6 Knight
also this Knight cannot move due to
Checkmate so you have to capture it now
Bishop captures and white is just
completely dominating the position here
so after Knight G5 Knight to G4 was
played attacking the bishop and Fabby
just moves it back we have Bishop to G7
and now Knight to F3 you have to defend
the pawn here so okay Fabby does go back
and now Rook eight to C8 seems rort has
finished development and uh Fabby goes
Knight to E4 now he controls a lot of
squares here and the raer has to be very
careful about what he plays next
probably uh best would be to play Knight
H6 followed by Knight to F5 it's a great
Square for the Knight attacks the bishop
attacks um the the D4 Pawn will put more
pressure but rapper played Pawn to C5
and it seems like a great idea you've
went um uh this long playing incredible
chess against a 2800 player or soon to
be officially 2800 player and you just
play C5 you want to get rid of your
backwards pawn and equalize the game
completely but this does not equalize it
completely Fabby played D captures and
C5 Queen captures and beat you Queen
captures Bishop captures and now Rook a
to B1 attacking the bishop Bishop back
to G7 and now Rook D to C1 so you've
traded down material is equal but Fabby
does have the the pass C Pawn which he
can already start pushing also he's
controlling the C7 Square so it could be
very unpleasant but still it's equal
material so you know that probably you
will be able to defend this so let's see
how raer plays it Bishop to H6 puts
pressure on The Rook Fabi moves it and
now Bishop back to f8 now puts more
pressure on this Pawn here and Fabby
advances it pawn to C6 we have Pawn to
F5 attacks the Knight uh Knight to G5
now you don't have F4 as it's guarded by
the bishop and by The Rook but you do
have to take care of the E6 Pawn that is
hanging so Rook to E8 by raer and now
Rook to B7 uh just uh gaining more
control over the board Fabby promotes
his Rook to a pig and now he controls
the seventh rank he's already
threatening to Capt on H7 so raer
defends it with Knight D7 uh there are
some other moves you could play here
like maybe Knight G to F6 but if you
play that you uh give up control over
the E5 square and now it's not even easy
to find the move for black let's say you
play Rook D7 uh just H3 you don't really
care about all that much here and if
Rook captures on C6 sort of removing the
defender of The Rook here you can even
trade down here because after Rook
captures you will play Rook captures on
A7 and now you have the outside past a
pawn and you're also going to lose the
E6 Pawn doesn't matter if you defend it
just Knight D4 will H pick up the pawn
so they're going to be down two pawns
and of course this will be very easy for
Fabby to win so he goes Knight to E7
instead now puts pressure on that C6
pawn and now just H3 chases away the
Knight Knight to F6 and now uh Faby goes
for Knight to E4 uh sorry Knight to D4
uh you could capture an E6 right away
but also your uh C6 Pawn is hanging so
fab just plays Knight to D4 attacks and
defend uh raer goes for Knight G to E6
captures it sorry first he attacks the
Knight and now Knight G captures uh on
E6 goes for the pawn Knight captures on
C6 we Knight captures on f8 uh Knight
captures on D4 and now Rook captures on
C8 Rook captures on C8 and Knight
captures on G6 uh Rook to C1 with check
King to H2 and now Knight to C6
defending the A7 pawn and it seems that
raport came out of this little Skirmish
down only one Pawn uh but uh you know uh
the reality could not be further from
the truth as Fabby plays Bishop to F4
shows that the Rook here and the pawn
can be attacked with the bishop so Rook
to C2 attacks the A2 Pawn seems Rapport
will also win something back but Fab
just plays Bishop captures on H6 and
shows that if you capture on A2 of
course none of you missed Rook to G7 is
Checkmate so after this capture uh now
he's down two pawns what can he do he
went for Knight to Knight to E8 but now
comes Knight to E7 with check this
guards against Checkmate so Knight to E7
check King to H7 attacking the bishop H
but now just Bishop to E3 and he was in
this position on move 40 that rard
Rapport resigned the game as there is
nothing more uh to be done here uh so
very very uh interesting um uh Choice uh
of of opening by Fabby and very nicely
play by both of them but it seems that
rapper played everything precise and
then at that one point he played C5 he
just wanted to get rid of that backwards
pawn and equalize the game Fabby said
nope uh that's that's what lost you the
game uh maybe it was possible to hold it
with some engine play but uh yeah yeah
not not by a human obviously and here
you resign because there's nothing for
you to do what do you do after this
bishop D3 move uh what can you even try
if you trade let's say Knight captures
on E7 then Rook captures with check and
you lose the Knight or you block with
Knight to G7 and then Bishop to D4 uh
you lose the Knight again so that's
definitely not the way to go if you try
King to h8 you unpin doesn't really
matter just Knight captures and C6 Rook
captures and now Rook captures on A7 uh
now you're are down three pawns and it's
hard to play being down one Pawn against
Fab being down three points uh pawns
would be would be Madness uh so there's
nothing to there's no move you can make
uh and if you make no moves then just
Knight captures will cost you a piece
and that's pretty much it uh so yeah
Fabby defeats alza he defeats Wesley and
now in the final rounds he round he
defeats rard Rapport and if he drew the
game he would be um sharing first place
with ler Dominguez Perez but as he won
uh he WI wins clear first place with 5
and a half points so really really
amazing stuff so Fabi goes from winning
the St Louis rapid and Blitz to winning
the seld cup at reaching 2,800 at the
end of the year and well I imagine he is
extremely happy he also is qualified
already for the for the candidates
tournament and uh I'm pretty sure that
uh he is U well he's very very confident
about his chances uh at the candidates
tournament 2024 uh what does this mean
for for the uh top ratings of the world
well not much Fabby now wins a little
bit more ratings he's now on 2804 so
still 2800 then we have hikaro and ding
then nepo then Wesley Dominguez Perez
lineer at 2756 ala fuja lost 26 points
uh it was a tough month for him then
karakin with nine and Anish giri in 10th
Place Anand always here hanging on uh
with 2748 and so on and so on some are
big Winners if you guys are interested
par makulu won 10 points this month
Vincent kimer 16 points vit up 22 points
Arjun up 14 points Notre Beck Four
Points um and also some of the big
Winners that are above 2700 are Yip Peno
and sarov and also Hans Neiman but he is
not 2700 just yet I think he's around
2695 or something like that uh but yeah
that's the game hope you guys enjoyed it
uh yeah and like I like I tweeted a bit
earlier seems that you know Magnus sort
of ruined classical chest for everyone
because it it didn't matter how good you
were you just didn't stand a chance
against Magnus but now that Magnus sort
of stepped down from the throne and he
allowed others to compete for the for
the world uh for the title of world
champion it seems that everyone is now
uh playing classical everyone loves
classical everyone is interested in
classical and everyone finally has a
chance so we'll see we'll see what
happens uh so yeah once again hope you
enjoyed it I would like to thank David
gasparian Muhammad Solan David Anthony
Robert his hantal and Dan schs for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing to check up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the Chess World uh so thank
you all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day